المعاناه تزداد والازمه تتفاقم في جميع
المدن الاوكرانيه لاسيما في العاصمه كيف
نتيجه استهداف الروس للبنيه التحتيه
للطاقه والتي اصبحت غير قادره على تغاطيه
حاجه الاستهلاك المحلي نهيك عن توقف صادر
الكهربائي الى الاتحاد الاوروبي كيف ام
مدن الروس كما يحلو للشعوب الصليبيه
مناداتها تغرق في ظلام دامس ويعيش مواطنها
ايام قاسيه ويتوقعون شتاء اقصى فلاد يحاول
ان يتكيف مع هذا الوضع الماساوي وان يجد
حلولا بديلا ويتمنى ان لا يضطر الى مغادره
مدينه
في النهار نقوم بشحنه لاستخدامه عندما
تقطع الكهرباء الكهرباء تقطع اربع ساعات
وتعاد لمده اربع ساعات اذا حدث وخرجت
الشبكه عن التغطيه تماما فلن يبقى لنا
شموع اما هذه الصيدليه فهي احدى صيدليات
شبكه صيدليات اوكرانيا الكهرباء مقطوعه في
المنطقه وبالتالي ايضا مقطوعه في الصيدليه
ولكنها تعمل
بالمولد سندخل ونتحدث اليهم ونعرف كيف هو
الوضع هنا في الصيدليه
الدراسه
لذلك توجد لدينا كهرباء والمواطنون يمكنهم
الحصول على الدواء المطلوب انقطاع
الكهرباء
ويتاثر قطاع المواصلات مما يفاقم الازمه
ويضاعف من معاناه المواطنين ويؤثر على
مداخلهم
انا اعمله للحلاقه نحن نعمل الان بحسب
جدول انقطاع الكهرباء
التي تعمل عن طريق الشاحن المتنقل
انقطاع الكهرباء يتكرر خلال اليوم عده
مرات تتوقف فيها الحياه لكن حتى هذه
اللحظه المواطنون قادرون على التاقلم مع
الامر الا ان الشتاء يزحف شيئا فشيئا
ودرجات الحراره ستنخفض حتى تصبح تحت الصفر
وعندها لن يفيد المواطنين تفهمهم وقد تلجا
الدوله لما وصفته بالحل الاخير وهو عمليه
اجلاء واسعه النطاق حتى لا يتجمد الناس
لقناتي العربيه والحدث حذف عادل كيف